رئيس الهيئه السعوديه مشاهدينا للفضاء
الدكتور محمد التميمي في تصريحات للعربيه
ومن مكان الانطلاق قال ان المملكه اصبحت
الاولى عربيا بارسالها ثلاثه رواد فضاء
الى محطه الفضاء الدولية التميمي اضافه ان
رائدى الفضاء السعوديين سينفذان 14 تجربه
علميه وطبيه ابرزها رفع كفاءه علاج
السرطان والامراض المزمنه بالاضافه الى
تجربه رفع كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار التي
ستنفذ للمره الاولى على محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
نهنئ القياده ونبارك لهم نجاح الاطلاق
وارسال اول رائده فضاء سعوديه وعربيه
ومسلمه واول رائد فضاء سعودي الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه نبارك للوطن بكل فخر
واعتزاز هذا الانجاز التاريخي في خدمه
الوطن والعلم والانسانيه وصدقا لم يكن هذا
الانجاز ليتحقق لول الدعم الكبير والتمكين
من سمو سيدي ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للفضاء قبل عده اسابيع التقى برواد الفضاء
واكرمهم بكلمات ملهمه ومحفزه هي وقود
الحماس والشغف لدى رواد الفضاء لما اطلعوا
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المهمه هي
احدى برامج
رواد الفضاء في تبع الخطه السنويه تبع
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للفضاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في رصيد المملكه
ثلاث رواد الفضاء فيصير ترتيبنا في على
مستوى جدول مجموعه العشرين التاسع ونحن
الاول على مستوى المنطقه في عهد الفضاء
الذين صعدوا الى المحطه الفضاء الدوليه
رواد الفرج يقوم بعده تجارب علميه عددها
14 تجربه علميه وطبيبيه من اهمها احدى
تجارب برفع الكفاءه علاج السرطان والامراض
المزمنه بالشراكه مع مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي والثاني تجربه جدا مهمه ولاول مره
تقام على محطه الفضاء الدوليه وهي لرفع
كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار ولها فائده الفائده
الاولى لرفع تقنيات الاستمطار على الارض
ومعالجه التحديات البيعه على الارض
والثاني ايضا لدراسه امكانيه الاستمرار
على الكواكب الاخرى وهذه التجربه بشراكه
مع جامعه الملك فهد والبترول والمعادن
[موسيقى]
اكس طيب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات